welcome back we are taking the saying
New Year New You to the next level
thanks to the help of Lifestyle expert
Samantha Vickers she joins us with some
great products to kick off 2023 always
so great to see you so good to see you
happy New Year happy New Year and I
found some fabulous stuff to make this
year awesome okay I'm excited let's jump
right into it okay let's start here so
new year new hair care routine with
viviscal so the FIFA scale is known for
its hair growth supplements but they
actually just launched some hair growth
products including the thickening
shampoo strengthening conditioner
exfoliating scalp scrub and thickening
serum and so these are going to work all
together so awesome to make your hair
beautiful and gorgeous it's going to
look great it's going to feel great it's
not going to break as easily and it
smells yummy if you want to take a smell
I do want to take a smell and you know I
love pink look at what I'm wearing um
the packaging is so cute it matches your
outfit I can smell the suit the bottle
it smells amazing so yummy I love it
okay let's move on over here now you can
get that at vivis
any major retailer great um this right
here we are going to level up our energy
this year with Lila Q Quantum Tech so
they are combining Quantum science
um Quantum energy healing and science so
this is actually a energy water bottle
wow and then I know so this you put your
water in it and it is going to be
infused with positive Quantum energy
when you drink it I love that I know and
these are here hold this okay you can
use this as a necklace put in your
pocket whatever you want to it is a heel
energy capsule and it has these little
titanium balls that have Quantum energy
so it's going to up level your energy
it's going to encourage balance boost
resilience and it's amazing and you can
find this at lilacue.com and they're
offering 10 off to all of our viewers
um with Las Vegas 10. staying hydrated
energize refresh everything we need in
the New Year something I'm loving tell
me about this okay so we can already see
the benefit of this right here we are
bringing the benefits of salt therapy
home this year this is the clear light
Halo one Halo therapy machine so this is
a Halo spray that's a salt spray that is
coming out right now and when you inhale
that you can improve your respiratory
function you can have your skin look
better fight infection it's great for
asthma sufferers and so it's portable as
you can see Tiny you can move it to any
room you can put it in your sauna and
you can actually get this at infrared
sauna.com this is great I know there are
a lot of benefits and to just be able to
have this in your home that is amazing
yeah
it is really cool and it's the Halo
therapy with Halo one it just makes it
easy these little pods that's all you
need you pop it in and you're good to go
quick and easy I love it all right and
last over here what do we have last but
not least you know your smile is one of
the first things that people notice when
they see you so let's make your smile
something that you're proud of this year
so the doctors that enhance cosmetic and
Implant Dentistry there's two locations
in the valley they are the experts on
cosmetic dentistry implants it doesn't
matter how small or big your needs are
for your smile they're going to take
care of you all you have to go is do is
go to
dentalenhanced.com and check out the
locations and book an appointment well
Samantha thank you so much if you guys
want to find any of these products just
find her on social media she always
shares all the good stuff so I know I'll
be having all this for the new year so
thank you very